Back in 2013,
I produced one of the strangest videos
on youtube,
a video about Arabic in Japanese with
English subtitles and me teaching in
Arabic lesson to Japanese viewers.
At the end,
lots of people were bewildered today.
I'm going to try it again.
Okay.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Arabic language or
as it's called in Arabic.
Arabic is the fifth most widely spoken
language in the world with $293 million
native speakers in 422 million speakers
in total.
It's an official language in 26
countries.
That doesn't mean it's the majority
language in all of those countries,
but it's one of the official languages.
It is also one of the six official
languages of the United Nations and
that's the language of the Quran,
the holy book of Islam.
It is also the liturgical language of
one point 7 billion Muslims around the
world.
Most of those people don't speak Arabic,
but many have some knowledge of Arabic
for reading and for reciting prayers and
religious study.
Speaking about Arabic can be confusing
because there are many different
varieties of the language.
One of the main varieties is the
classical Arabic of the coo,
Dan.
This is considered by many to be the
most perfect form of Arabic and some say
it's the only true Arabic because it was
the language in which God revealed that
to Mohammed.
Then there's modern standard Arabic
which is the form of Arabic used as an
official language today.
It's the modern form of literary Arabic
which was based on the classical Arabic
of the coo,
Dan,
but with some adaptations and a greatly
expanded vocabulary to make it more
suitable for modern times.
It's not exactly the same as classical
Arabic,
but both of them are referred to by
Arabs as hot meaning eloquent speech.
Modern Standard Arabic is the language
of books,
media,
education and formal situations but not
as the language of everyday speech.
For everyday speech,
Arabic speakers use their local dialects
or which can differ quite significantly
from country to country and even from
one place to another.
Within a single country.
Arabic is a Semitic language,
Arabic and other Semitic languages like
Hebrew,
Aramaic,
and Phoenician,
all developed from the same protose
Semitic language,
Arabic forms,
one branch of central submitting,
while another branch of central Semitic
includes Hebrew,
Aramaic,
and Phoenician,
old Arabic,
numerous Semitic languages related to
Arabic were spoken in Arabia between the
13th at Tenth Century Ce,
but they don't have features that would
classify them as Arabic.
The earliest evidence of people referred
to as Arab is in an Assyrian inscription
from the eighth century bce,
but it just mentions the Arabs.
It doesn't give any examples of their
language from the sixth century bce to
the fourth century ce,
we have inscriptions showing evidence of
an early form of Arabic.
Some of those inscriptions are written
in that early form of Arabic and others
are written in Aramaic,
but show some influence from Arabic.
Those inscriptions consists mostly of
proper names,
so they don't give us an awful lot of
information about what the language was
like.
The earliest inscription that is
unmistakably Arabic is from the first
century bce and was found at enough that
it's an Aramaic inscription,
but it contains three lines of Arabic.
Another inscription was discovered at
end the Mazda 120 kilometers southeast
of Damascus dating back to three slash
29 slash ce.
The language of this inscription is
nearly identical to classical Arabic as
we know it,
even though these inscriptions are
unmistakably written in Arabic,
they are not written in the Arabic
script,
but rather the Nabataeans script which
derived from the Aramaic script,
but there are also inscriptions from the
fourth and fifth century Ce that are
written in a script that's more like
Arabic.
It's generally thought that the Arabic
script developed from the Nabataeans
script and these inscriptions might be
written in a script that somewhere
between those two classical Arabic,
before the beginning of Islam,
there were numerous dialects of Arabic
spoken around the peninsula,
but there was also a common literary
language used among the different tribes
for poetry,
a coin it which was a compromise between
the various dialects.
The pieces of poetry written in this
literary coin a are the earliest
examples of classical Arabic.
The Koran was written in the seventh
century when Muslims believe that the
Qur'an was revealed to Muhammad by the
Angel Gabriel,
and then it was written down over a 23
year period.
At the time the Koran was written,
there were seven dialects of classical
Arabic.
The Koran was written in all of them,
but the ice version became the standard
upon which the text of today's call is
based.
The differences are in pronunciation,
not in vocabulary or grammar.
The Arabic of the [inaudible] is similar
to that of the pre-islamic classical
Arabic poetry,
but not exactly beginning during the
life of Mohammed and continuing into the
18th century,
the Islamic conquest spread the Arabic
language into new faraway lands.
After the Islamic conquest,
there was an important need to
standardize the language because of vast
numbers of people were beginning to
speak it.
The script was made,
more practical.
New Vocabulary was created and the
grammar and style of pro is West
standardized.
Neo,
Arabic and middle Arabic.
Classical Arabic was being standardized
as a written language.
Local dialects of Arabic also emerged in
the cities of the Arab empire.
These dialects did not descend directly
from classical Arabic,
but rather from pre-islamic Arabic
dialects or from a single Arabic coin,
which was the common language of
conquering Arab armies.
These new dialects were also influenced
by the original languages of areas that
were conquered.
The dialects of the lavant and
Mesopotamia were influenced by Aramaic.
The dialects of the Maghreb were
influenced by Berber.
The dialects of Egypt were influenced by
Coptic and so on.
The early centuries of these newly
emerging dialects are referred to as neo
Arabic,
even though classical Arabic was
standardized,
not everybody could write it perfectly.
Writing that contains features of both
classical Arabic and neo Arabic or
dialects is referred to as middle Arabic
middle refer to a time period,
but rather these texts were somewhere in
the middle between classical and
colloquial modern Arabic.
Over the centuries,
the neo Arabic dialects continued to
evolve into the modern colloquial
dialects of today,
but literary Arabic remains relatively
constant because the Arabic of the Koran
was always seen as the ideal Arabic to
imitate and this probably had a
conservative effect on the dialects
limiting them from changing too much.
After Napoleon entered Egypt in 1798,
the Arab world entered a period of
greater contact with the West.
The influx of new western concepts
required the Arabic language to be
updated in the early 20th century,
regional academies of the Arabic
language began a process of language
reform focused mainly on expanding and
updating the languages vocabulary.
These updates culminated in what is now
known as modern standard Arabic die
glossier.
Arabic is well known for its state of
Arabic speakers used two distinctly
different forms of the language in
parallel for different purposes.
Modern standard Arabic is not learned by
anyone as a native language,
but it's used in reading and writing and
media on children's TV shows ended
formal speeches,
while the colloquial dialects are used
almost universally for daily
conversation.
As I mentioned before,
there's quite a lot of variation amongst
Arabic dialects.
How well two speakers understand each
other,
depends on the geographic distance of
their dialects as well as exposure.
Many Arabic speakers have told me that
speakers up the Middle Eastern dialects
really have no trouble understanding
each other and that the main trouble
comes in understanding the my grubby
dialects,
especially Moroccan,
but these days with the spread of cable
TV and the Internet,
people are being exposed to a wider
range of dialects on a more regular
basis,
which helps people understand different
dialects more and of course there's also
our facade modern standard Arabic.
When speakers have significantly
different dialects communicate with each
other,
they can switch the modern standard
Arabic or they can adjust their speech
to make it more formal and literary and
similar to modern standard Arabic,
but not exactly another common way for
native speakers to bridge the dialect
gap is to use something called the white
dialect,
which is a more formal version of
dialectal speech that uses features that
are common to most of the different
dialects,
but it leaves out features that are
limited to specific dialects.
This is essentially a modern Arabic coin
a,
so what's Arabic like?
Let's take a look at some features of
Arabic focusing on modern standard
Arabic.
The script,
the Arabic script is written from right
to left and consists of letters that
imitate handwriting.
Most letters joined to the letter that
comes after them.
However,
a few letters remain disjoined.
The letters that joined have two forms,
one short form at the beginning or in
the middle of words and another long
form at the end of words,
or when the letter is by itself.
The Arabic script is an abject,
meaning that each letter represents a
consonant and that short vowels are not
really written in that long.
Vowels and diphthongs can be ambiguous.
How can we read Arabic without vowels?
Well,
can you read this here at the short,
vowels are not written and the other
seems somewhat incomplete,
but we have a hint about what the vowels
are.
This is kind of like reading Arabic,
but Arabic has more predictable vowel
patterns than English,
so it's easier to guess.
Also Arabic can be written with how cat,
which are extra diacritic markings that
indicate the short vowel sounds.
These are generally only used in texts
that are really important to pronounce
perfectly like the [inaudible] or poetry
or children's materials.
Phonology.
Arabic has a number of consonant sounds
which are surprising or challenging for
speakers of many other languages.
For example,
as in the word meaning Gulf.
Then there's off as in the word pin.
This is like the k but pronounced
further back in your throat.
Then there's the letter ha,
like in the word meaning hot in some say
that this is similar to the French are
sound.
For example,
the word meaning room Arabic also has a
number of infected consonants.
For example,
there's a scene which is like the
regular s sound in English,
but there is also sod,
which is an emphatic s as in the word,
meaning small.
Also notice design in the middle.
To make this sound,
do you have to keep your tongue close to
the roof of your mouth.
If you want to try it,
position your mouth as though you are
going to say a pe and hold that
position.
Then make an s sound.
Instead,
go ahead and try it.
Saw saw there are three other emphatic
consonants to an emphatic,
tall dog and zoll morphology.
Arabic words are mostly constructed from
three letter routes or sometimes four,
and these letters are then inserted into
templates consisting of a fixed vowel
pattern and some structural consonance.
If you know the route letters,
you can identify the core meaning of the
word and if you know the template,
you know what type of word it is.
Let's take the root ca at a gym,
which means to go out or to exit,
and let's put it into this template.
We get the word mythology,
which is the noun,
meaning exit,
like adore you,
exit through.
This template indicates a place where
the action of the root is done.
If we use the root data,
Ha Lem,
which means to come in,
we get mad.
The honey,
which means entrance.
If we use the root cath to bet we get
the meaning office.
These kinds of recurring templates help
you to know how to pronounce words even
when the short vowels are not written.
If you see the letter meme followed by
three route letters altogether with no
long vowels,
you can guess that the word is in this
template and pronounce it with too short
a vowels.
Verbs in Arabic are part of this same
system of roots and templates.
The templates tell us the tense person,
gender and number of the verb,
and the root provides us the core
meaning.
Again,
let's take the route at a gym and pump
it into this template here and we get,
and we know what this means.
It's the past tense.
Third Person,
masculine,
singular conjugation.
He exited.
This means he exited the school.
Now put the route into this template.
What this means,
I exited.
This suffix here indicates past tense,
first person singular out,
assuming that this means I exited the
office.
If we put it into this template,
yes,
it means he exits.
This is the present tense template.
This means he exits the office.
I mean they exit.
This means they will exit the office.
The sentences in the future tense to
change the present tense,
the future tense.
You simply add the suffix psa to the
beginning of the present tense template.
Sap is used for near future and a
separate particle so far is used for the
more distant future.
Arabic has no other verb tenses,
only past and present and future which
uses the present tense conjugation.
This submittal system of roots and
templates is really quite intuitive once
you get used to it,
and it's quite ingenious if you ask me
word order.
Modern standard Arabic is a vsl language
by default as opposed to Arabic
dialects,
which are mainly Svo.
You had this means the man is studying
Arabic.
Here's the verb,
the subject and the object.
These are the definite article,
but before certain letters,
the lamb or the l sound assimilates to
the following letter,
so I'll Rajul becomes our agile.
This is the basic word order,
but Svo is also possible in a sentence
with a pronoun.
VSL is not possible,
for example,
and a sofa.
A lot of.
Yeah,
this means I will study Arabic in the
future.
You can't say Sofa and a lot of Va.
You can either say it with the pronoun
first or with no pronouns,
just sofa because the verb conjugation
tells us that this is the first person
singular,
so we don't need the pronoun cases.
One aspect of standard arabic is cases.
There are three cases in arabic.
Nominative genitive and accusative
announced takes special endings to show
their function in the sentence.
Let's take the word keY tab,
which means book in nominative.
It's taboo in genitive.
It's keith rabie in accusative.
It's tabba.
This means the excellent book.
The noun key tab is in the nominative
and the adjective is also inflicted to
agree with the noun and then upload will
keep.
This means I am reading a book here.
Github is in the accusative and it's
indefinite.
The end sound at the end here indicates
that it's indefinite will.
This means so the author of the book
here,
key tab is in the genitive case.
These cases and things are not used at
the end of a sentence,
but only when the word is followed by
something.
the form at the end of a sentence
without a case ending is called the
Puzzle form.
These case endings are often not used in
modern standard arabic.
They're generally only used in prepared
texts are prepared.
Speeches,
two more sentences.
This means I usually don't work on
saturday word for word.
it's usually no,
I work day.
The saturday.
That is the negation particle used for
the present tense.
Amen is the verb for work and its root
is.
I'm meme lem and this is the first
person singular present tense,
conjugation,
yelm and accept around [inaudible].
So together they mean the day of
saturday you'd offer is a construction
of two nouns side by side to show
possession.
Fun fact.
The word sabbath comes from the hebrew
word shabbat,
which is related to this arabic word
sept.
Who would say,
this means I'll drive my car to the
office word for word.
It's will I drive my car to the office.
Remember,
saw is added to the present tense verb
to form the future of food contains the
verb cough while dad,
and this is the first person singular
present tense,
conjugation,
sayada.
It is the word sayada with a possessive
suffix,
meaning my at the end and when a suffix
is added,
the letter had becomes a tad.
Isla is a preposition showing direction.
The elbow here or the lamb is the
definite article al,
but the a sound or the eleaf assimilates
to the proceeding.
Long a.
As you can see,
arabic is a fascinating language with
lots of interesting features from its
script to it's phonology to its root and
template system.
It's a language that often seems
intimidating to learners,
but that's partly because modern
standard arabic materials are aimed at
reading and writing and grammar rather
than on communication materials for
learning arabic dialects tend to be more
fun and communicative.
The question that's asked over and over
and over is what form of arabic should I
learn a dialect or a modern standard
arabic,
in my opinion,
it's important to learn some modern
standard arabic either before you start
to learn a dialect or at the same time,
but if you know some modern standard
arabic,
it will help you to make sense of
different dialects that you encounter
and it will help you to understand
different registers of speech even when
people are speaking in their dialects,
but if your main goal is communication
than I don't think it's necessary to
learn to speak modern standard arabic at
a high level,
and that brings me to the question of
the day to native speakers of arabic and
to learners of arabic alike.
What do you think?
Which form of arabic is the best to
learn?
Modern standard arabic or a dialect?
Leave your answers in the comments down
below.
Be sure to follow lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
or instagram.
It's especially important these days
because weird things are happening with
youtube and nobody's really sure what
the future will bring,
so it's good to have a way to be in
touch with you outside of so I can let
you know what's happening with my videos
and in a worst case scenario where my
videos will be if not on youtube,
so be sure to follow me on at least one
of those and I want to say thanks again
as usual to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially these people right here on
the screen for their very helpful
monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.